-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
According to a new poll,
President Biden's approval
rating dropped to 39%.
But he's thinking
he can get that back up
once he's indicted a few times.
President Biden participated
in yesterday's
White House Demo Day,
showcasing new technologies
from across the country,
and was way
too easily impressed.
"Sir,
that's the office printer."
"Look at this thing."
Former President Trump
praised his daughter Ivanka
this morning ahead of her
taking the witness stand
at his civil fraud trial
and called her, "my wonderful
and beautiful daughter."
Weird,
when his sons were testifying,
he didn't have much
to say about them,
but now that it's Ivanka,
he's talking to her
like she has medical power
of attorney over him.
"My wonderful
and beautiful daughter
would never pull the plug
on her sick father.
I could recover.
A lot of people
are saying I could recover."
Ahead of Ivanka Trump's
testimony today,
former President Trump
complained in a post
on Truth Social that the judge
and state prosecutors
were, "making me look bad."
And then he sprayed
his face bronze,
combed his ear hair
to the center of his head,
yanked his tie down
to his knees,
and left the house for the day.
During a hearing yesterday
of the UK's official
coronavirus inquiry,
a former aide said
that then-Prime Minister
Boris Johnson
had asked at the start
of the pandemic
to be injected with Covid-19
live on television.
Way too risky,
said his advisers,
about putting him
live on television.
The Boris Johnson photo
just getting laughs.
Just getting laughs.
It's good every now
and then when you go,
"Yeah, we're not the only one
who had one of those."
They had -- Other people
had one of those.
Texas Senator Ted Cruz
said in a new interview
that he plans to run
for president again someday
and added, "I loved
running for president in 2016.
We came incredibly close.
We came within inches
of winning."
I guess in the same way
that the moon
is within 16 billion inches
of the Earth.
Texas Senator Ted Cruz released
his new book yesterday titled,
"Unwoke" How to Defeat
Cultural Marxism in America."
And if you really want
to be unwoke,
he also reads the audiobook.
[ Laughter ]
New York Mets owner Steve Cohen
yesterday unveiled his plans
for a new casino,
hotel, and music venue
near Citi Field,
which is expected
to cost $8 billion,
or roughly $1 billion
times as much as
the average Mets ticket
in September.
So much math in that joke.
Not just math,
but then calendar.
To get that punch line,
you had to do math,
then you had to do calendar,
then you had to do baseball.
I can't believe it went
as well as it did.
"People" magazine
announced yesterday
that it has named actor
Patrick Dempsey
The Sexiest Man Alive.
[ Cheers ]
You guys know we were
only supposed to set our clocks
back one hour, right?
I will say,
I read that joke first,
and then I saw a picture
and I'm like,
"Pretty [bleep] sexy."
I'm not complaining
about the pick.
And finally, three pandas from
the Smithsonian National Zoo
were returned to China today,
packed in a special crate
on a FedEx plane --
or as Southwest calls it,
Economy Plus.
And that was a monologue,
everybody.